dès le début j'ai commencé à me couper
profondément j'avais toujours besoin de
points de suture mais qu'il a été
toujours grande et profonde souvent ils
avaient besoin de me recoudre deux ou
trois fois
je me braque je me pique je me coupe je
me brûle j'aimerais aussi avec des
produits chimiques
dès que mes plaies commence à guérir je
fais tout pour les empêcher de se
refermer
aussi loin que je m'en souvienne j'ai
toujours eu au moins une plaie ouverte
sur mon corps
voilà c'est comme enel d'appel pour
qu'on nous aide parce qu'on peut pas
aider nous mêmes même des parents et
certains mammifères sont mêlés dans ces
cas-là il sont paniqués des parents
c'est obligé la plupart des jeunes gens
qui effectuent donc des scarifications
qui reste plus superficielle n'ont pas
pour objectif de se tuer ils ont pour
objectif de vider de se vider en quelque
sorte de leurs souffrances pour eux
c'est un moyen de 2 d'exprimer leur
souffrance et de la faire sortir
d'ailleurs souvent l'i10
je me fais du mal parce que ça me
soulage de me faire du mal
[Musique]
oui
centre hospitalier de bordeaux en france
beaucoup de jeunes accueillis dans ce
service se coupent se brûle se cassent
les eaux se scarifie régulièrement et
volontairement un comportement encore
tabou est souvent mal diagnostiquée par
le corps médical mais qui en france tous
seraient de plus en plus d'adolescents
camille julie et fanny ont entre 15 et
17 ans toutes les trois ont tenté de se
suicider toutes les trois simples ij
régulièrement des blessures elles sont
ici pour apprendre à se protéger d'elle
même pour essayer de comprendre pourquoi
elle éprouve l'irrésistible besoin de se
faire violence
comment t'as fait ça couteau
dans quelles circonstances
c'est à dire qu'est ce que tu ressentais
je m'estime achetés pour m je te promets
j'ai pris un bouton et je vais frire
charcutière je salue enfin la loi et par
contre j'en ai une petite tasse à ses
rasoirs passer un soir dans mon lit la
sage et avec une même de tags rien je me
suis fait d'abord la première croix et
après quand j'ai eu je me suis vraiment
énervé j'ai continué le trait hyper
forgé la première ag seigner
et après je me suis fait de petites
lames et même ça je les fais moins fort
et bon après béjart jauge été supprimés
tant taille crayon dire ça mais parce
qu'en fait c'est facile je dis ça avec
un conte page promener à l'âme gelé
guizeh je me suis fait là et là aussi la
ses pleins de coupures la cua partout
sur la main
sinon être un moyen d'expression quoi 2
montrer notre sujet c'est pas ça veut
dire qu'on est mal et qu'on fait lb je
peux pas pleuré j'ai énormément de
matches qu'un tournoi donc là je me
coupe ça me soulage sur le moment et
après je me dis qu'en fait ça m'a rien
fait ça m'a servi à rien mais je peux
pas m'empêcher de recommencer coin
regardez eu peur quand même puisque aziz
et pourquoi ma fille est pourquoi ma
fille a vu dans la souffrance même si
c'est pourquoi mais pourquoi ma fille
arrivée
et au point d'arriver là quoi pourquoi
pourquoi elle m'arrive là pourquoi doit
se faire du mal pourquoi de ce coupé se
détruire et ça lui fait mal corporelle
et moi j'étais mal aussi parce que
j'aime pas vraiment l'air s'offrir
laxistes c'est elle qu'il compte le plus
pour moi quoi
les bongo a donc j'essaie du parc de la
rassurer mais bon
voilà
ça fait dix ans que le docteur pommereau
a créé au sein de l'hôpital le centre
abadie la première unité française pour
adolescents et jeunes adultes suicidaire
c'est en s'apercevant que près de la
moitié des jeunes accueillis au centre
se scarifier que l'équipe médicale a
commencé à se pencher sur ce phénomène
méconnu si au cours de ce séjour est
passé par des moments d'effondrement
assez important avec passage à l'acte
puisque donc elle c'est une semaine de
sa
scarifié dans ce moment de profond
désarroi
c'est de réguler étaient effondrés ou du
blanc
de stylisation puis ensuite mieux elle a
aussi y est comme ça et finalement
priorité en quelque sorte va consister
effectivement à la
demande et de s'engager dans un travail
de sa souffrance mais ces cétacés sasson
c'est ça son boulot comme ça voilà alors
nous on a travaillé sur cette question
pourquoi parce qu'on s'est aperçu que
beaucoup de jeunes gens suicidaire alors
qu'ils mettaient leur vie véritablement
danger avait dans le passé commencé par
faire des scarifications donc c'était à
la fois donc un acte important en termes
de pronostic puisque pour un certain
nombre de jeunes gens effectuent des
scarifications à 13 ou 14 ans pouvait
ensuite s'accompagnait de tentatives de
suicide grave à 16 ou 17 ans donc on le
considère nous comme un signal d'alarmé
la plupart des adolescents qui
s'automutilent sont des filles les
garçons eux ont plutôt tendance à
extérioriser leur violence ils doivent
se battent conduite avec agressivité
mais ne retourne que très rarement cette
violence contre eux mêmes
cathy à 25 ans c'est son troisième
séjour au centre abadie elle a déjà
commis plusieurs tentatives de suicide
et se scarifie régulièrement il y adeux
nuit dans sa chambre d'hôpital elle
s'est tailladé l'avant bras à l'aide
d'un verre qu'elle a cassé ce n'est que
le lendemain matin en prenant sa tension
que les infirmières ont découvert la
blaise yeux
aujourd'hui le docteur pommereau soit
trop parlé de cet incident en
consultation individuelle comme
d'habitude l'un terne et une infirmière
sont également présentes
à ce moment là commence dans ta tête
comment ça s'est passé
est ce que tu te dis
qu'est-ce que cette faible de voir ton
premier
et j'avais envie que ça c'est une
confuse
je sais pas pourquoi j'ai fait ça
je dirais que c'est peut-être aussi les
pour
montrer la souffrance que j'ai
l'intérieur de moi la montre et
physiquement ouais
une démonstration voyage
est ce que tu fais un lien toit entre ça
et d'autres comportements que tu as pu
avoir auparavant
merde je sais pas trop parce que quand
je buvais beaucoup et enfin
quand je buvais est tout tout seul chez
moi et quand quand je fumais des joints
tu cites est plus dans le but
de pouvoir laisser le couler le temps et
ferme ou d'être tellement stone par là
parce que j'avais fumé de couper aux
idées j'avais mer ouais voilà
tu verrais d'autres exemples de coupures
au sens propre et au sens figuré que tu
as pu aussi quand j'étais chez ma mère
parce que vous pas dire c'est
des fois je faisais des faits pour que
les avis de me chercher
je veux bien que tu continues à
réfléchir sur cette histoire de couper
parce que je pense qu'il ya encore
d'autres façons
pour toi de décliner en quelques sortes
la coupure sans forcément d'ailleurs en
avoir pleinement conscience que c'est
aussi des coupures
tout séjour au centre commence lui aussi
symboliquement par une coupure pendant
les 48 premières heures les adolescents
n'ont le droit ni de sortir ni de se
servir du téléphone ni encore de
recevoir des visites le temps pour eux
de réfléchir à leur geste avant d'en
comprendre la signification cachée
cathy est ici depuis 20 jours et comme
c'est son troisième séjour elle restera
privé de tout contact avec l'extérieur
jusqu'à la fin de son hospitalisation
comme beaucoup de ceux qui sont ici elle
cherche dans son enfance à comprendre
les raisons de son mal être quand
j'étais jeune quoi j'étais à fouetter et
que fouet la ceinture et puis pour des
choses tellement anodine parfois
le cese justifie pas taper un enfant
mais
et même pas forcément des raisons
valables quoi
et c'est pour ça le fait de bras baissés
tout le temps je me rabaisse tout le
temps et psa moment j'ai besoin de
violence là parce que j'ai connu
beaucoup de ça
la plupart des jeunes gens qui vont mal
et qui sont dans une logique de rupture
très souvent c'est le sentiment de pas
se sentir exister de ne pas avoir de
place de ne pas avoir d' identité propre
un peu comme si faute de découvrir leurs
contours faute de pouvoir bien se
distinguer des autres de leurs parents
mais aussi des autres personnes il leur
fallait se déchirer il faut entendre le
mot au sens propre pour se doter d'une
identité d'une place dans une position
singulière comme s'il ne pouvait trouver
leur existence qu en se déchirant pour
contraster avec les gens qui les
entourent
aux états-unis comme souvent le
phénomène à une autre ampleur là bas ils
seraient au moins 2 millions à pratiquer
cette forme d'auto mutilation
comportement tabous comme en france les
américains y ont tout de même donné un
nom le coaching du verbe cote se couper
en anglais un terme qui regroupe tout
comportement consistant à s'infliger
volontairement des blessures corporelles
marylise trombi journaliste san
francisco elle a été l'une des premières
à révéler la détresse de centaines de
milliers d'américains dans un livre de
témoignages bouleversants
les personnes qui font ça le fond tant
qu hachette et se sont très isolés elles
ont l'impression qu'elles sont les seuls
au monde à avoir de telles pratiques
leur entourage les culpabiliser les
traite comme des monstres elles sont mal
reçus aux urgences certains psys sont
des diagnostics erronés ils disent celui
là fait une tentative de suicide ou
celui ci est masochiste
souvent ils ne les prennent pas au
sérieux et pensent que ces jeunes
cherchent juste attirer l'attention
comme si c'était une simple crise
d'adolescence
c'est notamment grâce à internet et à
l'anonymat qu'il garantit que mary lee a
pu vaincre la honte de ce qu'ils ont
accepté de témoigner pour l
internet est devenu cet outil
merveilleux où ils peuvent se retrouver
dans un environnement anonyme est sûre
ils peuvent qu'y apprendre les raisons
pour lesquelles il secoue et comment ils
peuvent arrêter
ils peuvent s'entraider échanger leur
histoire personnelle et s'exprimer
librement sur le net en effet on trouve
plus d'une centaine de sites consacrés
aux que ting des numéros de téléphone à
contacter en cas d'urgence des conseils
destinés aux familles et aux amis mais
aussi et surtout un nombre incroyable de
sites personnels ou des coasters parlent
de leur expérience et de leur détresse
le casting n'est pas réservé à une seule
catégorie sociale une des choses qui a
contribué à faire tomber le tabou et que
de nombreuses personnes célèbres ont
fait leur coming out en avouant qu'elle
était également d'écouteurs par exemple
il ya plein à moi angelina jolie a parlé
au magazine rolling stone de son
coaching elle a dit je comprends qu'on
ait besoin de voir son sang couler pour
se sentir en vie mais je ne veux plus le
faire j'ai trouvé d'autres façons
exprimer mes sentiments
nous sommes à naperville dans la
banlieue de chicago c'est dans cet
hôpital que se trouve le seul centre des
états unis exclusivement consacré aux
patients qui pratiquent cette forme
d'auto mutilation
je me laissais les bras les jambes vous
avez tellement mal à l'intérieur qui
leur fait mal à l'extérieur parce que
vous avez besoin dead
cette confession est extraite de
l'interview que la princesse diana
accordée à la bbc en 95 à l'époque le
testing était encore mal connu et tout
le monde a préféré parler des tendances
suicidaires de lady die aujourd'hui les
spécialistes de l'automutilation utilise
ses aveux princier pour déculpabiliser
les patients
ça fait du bien de voir que ce ne sont
pas que des gens lambda qui ont ce genre
de problème on aurait tendance à penser
qu'elle avait tout de l'argent du
pouvoir
c'était un modèle wi qui elle aussi
avait des problèmes
du coup tu te sens moins coupable
d'avoir le même problème
tu te sens - nul quoi
ces deux femmes carenco thériault et
wendy ladder ont fondé ce programme il
ya 16 ans il s'appelle safe alternatif
ici l'hospitalisation dure quatre
semaines la journée de soins coup de
7000 francs et le nombre de patients est
limité à 10 par session la plupart de
ceux qui viennent ici s'automutile
depuis des années ces patients ont
essayé tous les traitements toutes les
thérapies tous les services hospitaliers
pour eux safe alternative représente la
dernière chance de guérison
d'après ce que nous voyons ici les
personnes qui s'automutilent sont le
plus souvent des femmes
en général elles ont commencé à s'auto
infligé des blessures à la deux essence
voire plus jeune encore
elles ont une très mauvaise image
d'elle-même je dirais même qu'elle se
dégoûte
elles sont persuadées qu'elles sont
mauvaises maléfique qu'il ya quelque
chose de vraiment pourri on n
en général elles ont beaucoup de
vocabulaire et son brillant en tout cas
elles ont un qi équivalent au dessus de
la moyenne mais elles sont souvent issus
de familles où toute manifestation de
sentiments étaient censurés
libye à 23 ans pam 40 elles se sont
connues ici et partage la même chambre
depuis trois semaines
je me sens tellement coupable d'avoir
fait subir ça à ma fille m'aime ne t'a
jamais vue de couper non elle n'avait
que les points de suture comment tu fais
pour le lui cacher je le fais quand elle
n'est pas là quand elle est à l'école
comment ça tu retiens tu as pulsions
jusqu'à ce qu'elle soit partie tu sais
moi mes pulsions c'est toujours entre 13
et 16 heures assez dingue
pour moi c'est quotidien c'est même
plusieurs fois par jour ma journée est
organisée autour de l'automutilation
je me demande combien de fois quand et
comment je vais pouvoir le faire est-ce
que je vais me sentir coupable ou pas
est ce que je vais me sentir coupable de
ne mettre pas suffisamment mutilés vous
voyez pour moi l'automutilation est une
manière de me punir mais aussi parfois
de me récompenser par exemple je peux me
dire aujourd'hui j'ai vraiment eu une
sale journée je mérite de me couper ou
alors si je suis très fatigué et molle
et que j'ai besoin d'un coup de fouet je
peux aussi moto mutilés et vous
retrouver la pêche c'est comme un show
d'endorphines enfin si je suis trop
excitée que j'ai besoin de me calmer je
peux aussi me faire mal et ça va me
relaxer et m'apaiser bref ça me sert
dans de nombreuses circonstances ça
faisait mal non à l'époque où je le
faisais ça ne faisait pas mal du tout je
crois que l'adrénaline libère des
endorphines et que ça anesthésie la
douleur c'est comme quand un choc
ou alors c'est peut-être parce que quand
j'étais gamine j'ai appris à bloquer la
douleur
un truc vraiment bizarre que je n'ai
réalisé que dernièrement
petit j'ai été violée
on pénétrait avec des couteaux et
d'autres ustensiles de cuisine c'est
vrai sont des services extrêmement
violent et
c'est bizarre je n'avais jamais fait le
rapprochement mais maintenant c'est moi
qui utilise ses couteaux sur mon propre
corps alors qu'avant c'était quelqu'un
doit être vous comprenez j'ai passé
tellement de temps sans avoir le moindre
contrôle sur moi même je n'avais de
contrôle sur rien jamais alors
l'automutilation pour moi même
aujourd'hui est la seule chose que je
contrôle et c'est pour ça que c'est si
difficile d'y renoncer
ici toutes les patientes sont
volontaires et accepte de suivre à la
lettre un règlement intérieur draconien
dès leur admission elle signe un contrat
selon lequel elle s'engage par écrit à
ne pas s'auto mutiler pendant toute la
durée du séjour sous peine d'être
renvoyés immédiatement du centre en
échange on leur apprend à se servir
d'outils sont c'est canaliser leurs
pulsions et leur éviter le passage à
l'acte comme par exemple ce carnet
libye tu fais quoi je remplis mon carnet
de pulsions c'est quoi
c'est quand tu as une envie
irrépressible de te blesser
ils veulent ici que tu réfléchis c'est
ce qui se passe derrière
réfléchir ou penser aux sentiments qui
te pousse à vouloir passer à l'acte il
faut noter l'heure le contexte comme ça
tu peux aussi voir si tu as tendance à
répéter des schémas
par exemple moi je ne suis rendu compte
que j'avais mes pulsions plus tôt le
soir il faut aussi analyser les causes
de tes pulsions
réfléchir aux conséquences
ça t'oblige à comprendre ce que tu
essayé de dire à travers des actes
plutôt qu'en utilisant des monts tu dois
écrire ce que tu as fait au lieu de te
blesser et quelles sont les conséquences
de cette victoire sur toi même
ce programme est basé en grande partie
sur des réunions de groupe entre 6 et 7
par jour au cours de celle-ci une
thérapeute passe en revue et décortique
les carnets de pulsions l'occasion
d'aller fouiller au plus profond des
inhibitions et des blessures de chacun
plus de la moitié des femmes présentes
ici ont subi des violences sexuelles
dans leur enfance
la plupart par un membre de leur propre
famille l'une des priorités est donc
d'essayer de les réconcilier avec un
corps qui les révulse et quelle violente
ma dernière pulsions je l'eus matin je
voulais moto mutilés pour me punir
ça s'est passé ce matin 10h dans la
pièce commune
je venais tout juste d'avoir un
entretien individuel avec la psychiatre
je me sentais dégoûté menace est
angoissé j'avais peur et je me sentais
vulnérables en fait ce matin la
psychiatre de peggy lui a tout
simplement suggéré d'essayer de
réapprivoiser son corps en lui donnant
du plaisir de lui faire du bien plutôt
que de toujours l'agresser
une idée insupportable qui terrorise
encore la plupart des femmes présentes
ici mais si tu sais très bien de quoi je
veux parler de mise
c'est de masturbation
hameau ciel me l'a suggéré mais je crois
que je me sentirai trop coupable
je crois que j'en serais bien incapable
c'est pas naturel
donc si je comprends bien la plupart des
familles s'ils ne connaissent pas leur
propre corps vos corps ont été violées
par d'autres mais joue vous ne
connaissez rien à votre propre corps
regardez les mines que vous faites
f s mais c'est pas bien ça qui a dix
mois
et il faut que je suis tellement écoeuré
j'apprenne à connaître mon propre corps
et que je sache
ce que j'aime
parce qu'à chaque fois que j'ai une
relation sentimentale
dès qu'il était question de choses plus
intimes je ne pouvais rien faire d'autre
que de motos mutilés donc je suppose que
la seule solution pour surmonter cela
c'est de commencer à me sentir mieux
avec mon corps
qu'est ce qui se passe en russie corona
d'accord
c'est ton premier gros pour je sais ce
n'est pas un sujet facile
respire
de dire ce qui se passe ce que tu
ressens
je ne sais pas ce qui se passe je ne
comprends pas ce que je ressens
l'expression orale est extrêmement
importante pour ces personnes imaginez
un enfant de deux ans il ne maîtrise pas
langage ils utilisent des comportements
pour communiquer à ses parents ce dont
il a besoin
l'automutilation est très comparable ce
que font les enfants qui ne savent pas
encore parlé ils utilisent leur
comportement pour dire qu'ils ont mal
qui sont en colère qui sont tristes
notre objectif de pousser nos patients a
utilisé un langage adapté à leur âge
[Applaudissements]
en alternance avec les réunions de
groupe toujours très violente sur le
plan émotionnel l'équipe médicale
organise des séances d'expression par le
dessin les traits et les couleurs
remplace alors les mots encore trop
difficile à prononcer
aujourd'hui chaque patiente doit essayer
de mettre une image sur les sentiments
qu'elle éprouve un
peggy qu'est ce que tu ressens
ça veut dire quoi cette tête que tu fais
ta colère a l'air bien maîtrisé la
salers contenu ce volcan n'est pas en
éruption
tu crois que tu n'as pas le droit
d'exprimer sa colère
je crois que je n'ai pas le droit
d'exprimer quoi que ce soit
il ya du temps si tu as le droit
d'exprimer sa colère
je n'ai pas aimé ça du tout pourquoi
parce que ça a raconté trop de choses
sur moi
c'est comme ça que ça marche la thérapie
par là ça fait parler l'inconscient et
c'est comme ça que tu apprends beaucoup
de choses sur toi même
tous les membres de ma famille à part ma
mère était physiquement très violent dès
qu'il se mettait en colère il ne se
maîtrisait plus et s'en prenait
physiquement aux gens
je me suis juré que je ne serai jamais
comme du coup j'ai tout intérioriser
j'intériorise tout depuis que j'ai 14
ans
l'automutilation était l'un des moyens
que j'avais pour faire sortir ma colère
je la retourner contre moi même
j'espère que je pourrai m'en sortir et
vivre ma vie
et si cela veut dire qu'il faut que je
tourne le dos ma famille alors je le
ferai
il faut que je commence à vivre pour moi
et que j'arrête de vivre pour les autres
c'est difficile
très difficile
parce que même s'ils sont tous dingues
dans ma famille c'est quand même la
seule famille que j'ai
et c'est dur de renoncer à une famille
cela fait maintenant 22 jours que libye
et pam ne se sont pas mutiler un record
dans leur vie dans une semaine elle
quitte le centre pour que leur retour
dans le monde ne soit pas trop brutal
pour qu'elles réapprennent à affronter
les situations réelles de la vie elles
sont régulièrement autorisé à sortir des
locaux de l'unité
pour moi c'est un défi de faire mes
courses en plein jour d'habitude
j'attends qu'il soit 2 ou 3 heures du
matin et je vais dans les magasins
ouverts 24 heures sur 24
je fais pas mes courses la journée
pourquoi pas
mais à cause de l'automutilation
et puis je ne me sens pas très à l'aise
quand il ya du monde j'évite le monde
bref c'est un défi et c'est chouette
parce que pour l'instant je trouve que
je m'en sors plutôt pas mal
c'est marrant parce que la question dans
l'autre magasin m'a demandé mais qu'est
ce qui vous est arrivé et ça m'a glacé
parce que je ne savais absolument pas
quoi lui répondre alors je dis ben c'est
une longue histoire elle m'a fait à ok
mais elle a continué à me regarder avec
insistance j'étais mal alors on s'est
dépêché et on est sorti aussi vite que
possible
[Musique]
des doubles lames
et en plus elles sont soldés et j'ai du
mal à résister au sol
est en train de les toucher repose
repose moi c'est celle là que je préfère
non j'aime
c'est celle là que j'aime
c'est vraiment difficile de les ignorer
surtout qu'elles sont en solde ouais
rien que de les regarder c'est toi tu es
en train de flipper qu'est ce que ça
vous fait
une pulsion ou à une pulsion
vous savez en temps normal quand je fais
des courses je prends toujours des trois
paquets pour être sûr de ne pas en
manquer les lames sont tellement flynn
que je peux les cacher n'importe où et
il ya dilemme par paquet enfin enfin
bref je crois qu'on ferait mieux de
passer ce rayon parce que ça me rend
très nerveux
vous sortez dans huit jours et vous avez
toujours envie d'en acheter la
différence c'est que maintenant on
arrive à les reposer on les repose on
l'aimé plus dans le caddie pour les
ramener à la maison ça c'est un grand
pas pour moi
trop mignon
mais j'en prends quand même un regard
dit là une grenouille sur la tête
retour au centre brille une jeune
patiente de 25 ans fait ses adieux à
libye ce soir elle rentre chez elle
comme toujours chaque départ suscite les
mêmes angoisses les mêmes questions
on était en train de se demander si on a
les cacher nos cicatrices ou si on
allait les garder jusqu'à la fin de nos
jours
justement j'ai rencontré une fille si à
l'unité qui voulait devenir chirurgien
plasticien elle voulait surtout se
spécialiser dans les méthodes pour
effacer les cicatrices en particulier
pour ceux qui se sont automutilés
mais j'ai entendu dire aussi que grâce à
la chirurgie esthétique on pouvait
maintenant effacer ses cicatrices mais
je ne crois pas que je le ferai je
préfère les garder pour montrer ce par
quoi je suis passé pour ne pas
recommencer
si je les ai face j'ai peur d'oublier
bref il va falloir de toute façon qu'on
assume nos cicatrices et qu'on apprenne
à vivre avec
c'est un épisode de notre vie
alors bien sûr je suis sûr que nous
serons critiqués que certaines personnes
nous dirons tu es folle t'es bizarre
mais pas si ce sont de véritables amis
je suis arrivé à un point dans ma vie où
j'en ai assez de me cacher plus je me
cachais plus j'ai honte et je ne veux
plus avoir honte de qui je suis
d'ailleurs c'est un miracle si je suis
toujours en vie aujourd'hui
et ce miracle je le dois à
l'automutilation avec tout ce qui m'est
arrivé dans ma vie l'automutilation est
la seule chose qui m'a permis de me
soulager et de le calmer au lieu de
péter les plombs
en 16 ans petit à petit safe alternative
a réussi à lever un tabou son programme
est reconnue et l'équipe reçoit
aujourd'hui plus de 500 appels par mois
les résultats sont là deux années après
leur sortie du centre 75% des patients
n'auraient pas récidiver safe cherche
maintenant à lever des fonds pour
faciliter l'hospitalisation du plus
grand nombre
[Musique]